when the militants arrived in Marui City
Mohammad was nine months pregnant they
escaped on the back of her husband's
motorbike and she gave birth to baby
rawhide ahem the evacuation center but
Amina miles
[Music]
they're living less than three miles
from the front line in a camp around the
town hall the children are lined up to
be photographed for an emergency feeding
program program the village clinic has
become a basic Hospital young boy is
rushed in with a head injury
he's fallen outside in the rain he needs
stitches but he'll be okay
this mother brought her son in earlier
today he's being treated for severe
dehydration on another camp head one
year old Abdul hooked up to a drip
suffering from diarrhea his family
walked here from Marawi almost all of
the quarter of a million people who
lived in Marah we have had to leave
their homes the emergency shelters are
basic and it's the rainy season the
longer the fighting goes on the more
serious the humanitarian situations
nearest becoming they've already been to
cases
polar ahem the camps and the real
concern now is the potential for the
spread of malaria and dengue fever with
so many people here now living in such
private spaces more than 3000 people
live in this camp we saw four working
toilets we want a regular uninterrupted
supply of clean water and then toilets
for them to use and of course a descent
living condition the evacuation center
is way below the threshold of any human
being but you know people content
themselves we are surviving we are all
survivors here this is the queue for
daily rations the older residents are
brought to the front they're grateful
for what they're getting here that this
is now the second month of living like
this they don't know when they'll be
able to go home Katy stalard Sky News
segi Hren